su bóveda ocupa la mayor parte del
espacio del cementerio de predapio el
lugar de descanso eterno de Benito
Mussolini en el pequeño Pueblo donde
nació se ha convertido en un santuario
al padre del fascismo atrae a unos
70.000 visitantes al año que depositan
flores y velas una especie de
peregrinación impulsada por la nostalgia
de lo que consideran una época dorada de
Ley y orden bajo el Antiguo dictador
si se revisa bien la historia de Italia
Mussolini hizo muchas cosas buenas por
Italia
yuste la agricultura la seguridad social
los hospitales
quizá con alguien como él los demás
políticos se callarían dejarían de
pelearse y harían algo
más de 70 años después de que nazis y
fascistas casi destruyeran Europa su
imagen resurge aquí
su símbolo se exhiben en los escaparates
como esta tienda de recuerdos que vende
camisetas con Saludos fascistas o
banderas con esvásticas pero no todos
los habitantes de pedapio lo aprueban
toda esta nostalgia Por una parte tan
oscura de la historia de nuestro país y
del mundo me incomoda
esta nostalgia ha contribuido a allanar
el camino para el aumento del apoyo a
los hermanos de Italia de extrema
derecha su líder Georgia meloni dice
ahora que no hay lugar para el fascismo
en su partido Aunque sigue luciendo en
su logotipo la llama tricolor utilizada
por los partidarios de Mussolini tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial desde su caída
ninguna figura extrema derecha ha estado
tan cerca de liderar Italia